posez votre question on vous trouve
l'info je rassurais pour ça avez vous
remarqué les publicités des compagnies
d'assurances des jardins propose un
nouveau mot valise rassurance
industrielle alliance un éléphant
sécurisant et promutuel est là l'eau et
l'eau en voyant cette publicité de
promutuel diane de laval a eu un doute
ce sont des enfants qui causent des
dégâts c'est de la négligence
je ne crois vraiment pas que les
compagnies d'assurances couvrent ce
titre de dommages qu'en pensez vous je
rassure et % eh bien oui même si vous
avez été négligent vous serez indemnisé
les assureurs ont découvert que leurs
clients comprennent mal cette notion en
assurance en fait qu prête tout même de
vous est généralement couvert lorsque
vous avez un contrat d'assurance tous
risques
par contre certains autres contrats ont
des exclusions qui pourraient faire en
sorte que l'assureur ne serait plus
tant que ce n'est pas intentionnel ou
criminelle vous êtes couverts même si
vous avez été négligents passer le mot
[Musique]